well the las vegas raiders are getting
ready to play one of the biggest games
of their season it's scheduled for
sunday night they're hosting tom brady
in the box
but as john treach reports tonight that
game is in question because there's no
question the nfl
can't tackle this vicious virus at least
we saw tom brady and his six
glimmering super bowl rings coming as
for kovid
well it's far less predictable and far
more dangerous
and it could result in a backup plan and
a whole lot of backups for the raiders
this sunday
trent brown is not here today his status
is unknown we had to send
five of our starting linemen home today
because they had a tracer i guess they
were around
trent i can't get into things any more
than that trent brown the league's most
mountainous man sidelined by an
invisible monster
and forcing a line change never seen in
the history of football practice
you got to have lyman to play and we'll
have five on sunday we'll be ready to go
well maybe we do know even for the
franchise that brought us the michael
crabtree versus
akeeb tilly fight over ripped chain the
marshawn lynch getting ejected and then
riding the subway home
and the entire antonio brown traveling
circus
this episode may take the crazy cake it
ranks number one in the weirdest things
and i've you all know we've seen a lot
of weird things around here in my seven
years
but this is definitely up there with
some of the weirdest things i've ever
seen
the raiders find out tomorrow who is in
the clear or if everyone should steer
clear of playing on sunday
taking on tom brady would just be too
simple for 2020.
john treach 8 sports now